We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P I I don't, I don't
want to pick on the person that left this
voicemail, but it's an example of a problem.
I've said a lot of people haven't read the
Mueller report. Take a listen to this voicemail.
Okay.
Hello is David Pakman? My name is Raquel.
I'll have fun in a long time listener. I am
here and this is probably something that a
lot of people are curious about. How does
one gets access to the Miller report? We go
through the freedom of information act requests
for it. Is it something that you can get in?
You can go to the library and then they can
access it for you. I'm not sure how to get
that, so I'm wanting to read it and I'm just
curious how average person would get ahold
of her.
Yeah. Listen, I, I'm not trying to, I'm not
making fun of anyone. I'm not picking on you.
This is a massive problem in society. Okay.
The Mueller report has been out everywhere
on the Internet for for weeks. At this point
you just go to Google, you type in Mueller
report, full text. There will be hundreds
of results websites that have uploaded it.
It's, it's, it's widely available. The Department
of Justice released it, so I've talked about,
we have a problem in this country where a
lot of people haven't actually read the report.
They're going by what Barr said or whatever.
It's also, this is not the only message I've
gotten like this from people who they don't
know. They were under the impression, I'm
struggling for words here cause I want to,
I want to be respectful and polite. People
are trying to figure out, well, where can
I even find this thing? You just Google it.
It, it comes up, right, right away. Okay.
Um, I'm feeling a little depressed. I'm not
going to lie after that, but let's read this
thing. It's widely available
on the bonus show today. I've got a big announcement,
very, very big announcement. Get the bonus
show, become a member. I think everybody,
but the hatred. It's will like this announced,
speak to you.